let me start with tonight's game are you
surprised Washington is favored in this
game time I guess a little bit just
because you know Stanford has clearly
been the team to beat in this league and
they've had the upper hand in this
series you know over the last several
years but on the other hand you know I
think Washington poses a real problem
for you know for Stanford in what they
can do and what the talent they have and
I think the crowd is going to
potentially be a real factor in the
favor of Washington tonight as well what
does Christian McCaffrey have to do now
to win a Heisman well I don't know that
he can match the kind of numbers that he
had last year so I don't know that it's
a matter of numbers I think that he is
showing a little more versatility this
year they're utilizing him more as a
wide receiver in some sets and he has
worked to develop that part of his game
I think he's a phenomenal football
player I the thing that that he has no
control over is a lot of the games that
he plays not everybody sees you know I
mean now this game tonight is a national
stage and it's the only game out there
and he'll hopefully have a large
audience see him perform tonight but you
know that he doesn't have as many games
I don't think as deshaun Watson and
Lamar Jackson are going to have like
that game on Saturday night at Clemson
it just feels like he's competing
against himself and he doesn't have
numbers that come close to what he did
last year the only way he's going to win
it is somebody gives him a lifetime
achievement Iseman yeah well and I think
you know if Stanford makes it to the
playoffs I think that would be a huge
thing in his benefit because I think
people recognize it he's a great
football player and and you know his
numbers are still going to be impressive
I mean it it's still pretty amazing that
even though his streak of consecutive
games with over 200 yards of all-purpose
yards got stopped last week at Arizona
he still has 18 consecutive games over a
hundred yards and the total yards is
over for
in those games so I mean he he continues
to produce I think if Stanford is able
to to win this game tonight and continue
winning and find themselves in position
to make the the four-team playoff I
think that would go a long long way for
Christian McCaffrey sneaky game with
Wisconsin at Michigan Wisconsin I don't
think many people gave them a chance at
Michigan State or even at home against
LSU so handicapped this game with
Wisconsin and Michigan well again I I've
not seen Wisconsin very much but but
obviously I know that Paul chris is a
good football coach you know they lost
their defensive coordinator LSU they
turn around and beat LSU the first game
I think they're a team that they get the
most out of their guys and and they play
really tough they play really physical
it's the kind of team that Jim Harbaugh
would probably love you know so i think
it's it's two teams are going to play a
very similar style in that game both
want to establish the run both want to
have some balance in there in there with
their pass game and play great defense
so I think Michigan is probably a little
bit better but I think Wisconsin comes
into that game with tremendous
confidence having one to two pretty
serious games already it's Michigan good
or just perceived as good because of Jim
Harbaugh you know I'm going to go to
that game after my game is done I'm
gonna stand there and watch that one in
person and I have a better idea how to
answer that I think they are good i
think they you know i think last year
they overachieved because it was
basically the same players that they had
before when they weren't that good and I
think he made them good and made them
play with a certain mentality and a
certain style that made them better than
they were this year I think that they're
better because I think they've recruited
and they have more talent but I don't
know how good yet I'm curious to see for
myself he's Todd Blackledge shall have
the call tonight it'll be Stanford in
Washington that'll be at nine Eastern on
ESPN more important for Louisville and
Lamar Jackson or Clemson and deshaun
Watson this game as weekend
I think it's equally important and I
really do I think it's a great football
game you know Lamar Jackson has been off
the charts here this first month but I
don't think that he or louisville has
faced a defense the caliber of Clemson
yet and and I say that because I think
everybody expected Florida State's
defense to be outstanding but then
they've got some problems you know they
turned around and gave up 35 points to
South Florida last week so I think
Clemson will be a truer test defensively
for Lamar Jackson and you know the other
thing that that gets lost a little bit
in that game not completely but you know
in big games particularly it shows up as
good as Lamar Jackson is Bobby Petrino
is as good of a play-caller as there is
in college football I think I mean he
really has a feel for that and does a
great job with that and of course he has
a special guy to call plays for and you
know deshaun Watson it's interesting too
if you really look closely at his
numbers you know Clemson is is is often
just as good of a start offensively as
they were through the first four games
last year some of his numbers are a
little bit down but I think offensively
that's a team that is getting better and
better and I would expect to see I would
expect to see Clemson play their best
game of the year Saturday night how
surprised were you that Les Miles was
fired what was that how surprised were
you that Les Miles was fired well a
little bit surprised you know I on the
one hand not because they've been kind
of after him for a long time and and I
was surprised because I think overall
he's been really really good for LSU and
really good for those players the one
thing I always noticed about LSU's teams
is you know those kids loved playing for
him they played really really hard for
him they were a little bit behind
offensively where I think they should
have been they weren't the greatest at
clock management at times I mean they
they had their issues but but I think
overall he was really good for LSU as a
program and so that part of it
surprising but you know again the people
down there they have super high
expectations you know they had Nick
Saban there for a period of time he won
a championship he left he went to
Alabama and he's established something
at Alabama that I think everybody in
that league aspires to and I think it's
frustrated was frustrating for the
people there that they felt like they
were so far behind them I bring up the
fact that what Dan Marino was able to do
in the NFL if you had today's game and
marina was allowed to do what he did
with the dolphins he's throwing for
close to six thousand yards I'm going to
guess and and you know maybe that's
overestimating but you came out in that
draft and the style of play in college
football you know her high school over
college with quarterbacks completely
different than it is now why was Marino
ahead of the curve and this is 1984 Todd
that he was putting up these kind of
numbers that you're seeing all of these
quarterbacks but up now well he had
tremendous skill for one thing I you
know and he everybody talked about his
release and his accuracy and his ability
to throw the ball down the field I mean
he had all of that and he was a you know
a lot of teams are kind of enamoured now
with more the dual-threat kind of
quarterback he was not bad but he was
very he had nimble feet in the pocket he
was able to move in the pocket and buy
himself time but you know he played in a
very passer friendly offensive pit and
and you know went to a team in Miami
where they had some good pieces around
him with receivers and an offensive line
and and he just he blossomed you know he
but he he fitted it fit him and he fit
the system really well at Pitt and he
fit the system really well in Miami and
and then the skill on top of that you
know was how he was able to produce so
well but is it hyperbole to say he could
throw for 6,000 yards today uh he would
be right up in there I mean he would be
throwing as well if not better than
anybody in the league I mean that that
his skill set would have you know what
it continued to be really really strong
in today's game tato biga calling the
game with Joe Tessitore and Holly
oh please tell Holly we settle oh one of
our favor will ya great great woman
Stanford and washing tonight on the
mothership at nine Eastern Todd good to
visit with you thanks safe travels okay
damn thang all right the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience